ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States
thank you very much please thank you
good afternoon and before we begin five
years ago nine innocent parishioners of
a historically black church you will
remember this horrible event were
tragically killed during an evening
Bible study in Charleston South Carolina
that was a despicable act of evil today
we remember the somber day as a heart
still break for the victims and our
prayers go with all that was a terrible
event it was a terrible day terrible
terrible day for a country for the world
to witness thank you very much for being
with us at the White House as we
reaffirm our sacred promise to support
and protect your great veterans we love
our veterans and great they are with
honor and courage these incredible
Patriots perform their duty to America
and now we must fulfill our duty to them
and that's what we're doing
and we're doing it beyond what anyone's
ever done as president or as an
administration we're gathered together
to address an especially urgent struggle
today we're unveiling our roadmap to
empower veterans and end the national
tragedy of suicide tremendous problem
tremendous tremendous problem my
administration is marshalling every
resource to stop the crisis of veteran
suicide and protect our nation's most
treasured heroes they've been through so
much and it's such a deep-seated problem
and we're doing tremendous research and
everything you can do but it is
something that nobody quite understands
and they a gaining knowledge but they
don't quite understand it and I want to
thank our vice president for being with
us and I especially want to thank
frankly wonderful Karen pence who
was so committed to the veterans and
this particular problem and thank you
very much Karen we appreciate
here as well or several members of
prevents task force prevents its cult
prevents Secretary of Veterans Affairs
Robert Wilkie Robert great job
ninety percent approval rating the VA
it's way way up ninety percent that has
never not even come close to attaining
that number so it's a tremendous job
you're doing thank you very much
Secretary of Labor Jeanne Scalia Jeanne
thank you very much
Secretary of Health and Human Services
Alex a czar Alex Thank You Secretary of
Housing and Urban Housing and Urban
Development the great ben Carson thank
you Ben Secretary of Education Betsy
DeVos thanks Betsy Ann acting director
of OMB Russ vote Thank You Russ very
much
also with us our Surgeon General Jerome
Adams where's Jerome Jerome hi Jerome
and he got a standing ovation the other
day I introduced him he got the only
standing ovation Jerome what was that
all about and the executive director of
prevents task force dr. Barbara van
Dalen
thank you very much appreciate it thank
you thank you Barbara and
representatives from several of our
nation's leading veterans groups we have
tremendous people in this room people
that worked so hard for the veterans and
they love our military they love our
country they love our veterans thank you
all for being here very much very much
appreciated from day one my
administration has been on a mission of
historic scope and scale to deliver
results for our great veterans after
years of shameful scandal and neglect
under the obama-biden administration and
scandal and that lect it was we have
fundamentally reorganized the VA from
top to bottom and we've reestablished
a crucial principle American veterans
deserve the highest standard of care
anywhere in the world and that's what
they're getting great leadership to help
veterans get the care they need when
they need it we approve veterans choice
and made it permanent and that was a big
deal they've been trying to get it for
decades and decades and decades and we
got it we got it done and basically that
means if you have a problem and you
can't get to a doctor it doesn't work
you end up going outside you get your
doctor we pay the bill and they get
immediate service some of the veterans
were false and past administrations for
a long time beyond the Obama
administration even but for a long time
they were expected to wait a week in two
weeks and three weeks just to get to see
a doctor it was a terrible situation now
we have veterans choice they've been
trying to get it so long and it works
incredibly well and I would say that's a
reason why when I say ninety percent
approval rating that's probably one of
the big reasons before I took office
every month seemed to bring a new story
of crisis at the VA by our friends from
the media but the days of endless and
deadly wait lists are over and they are
never going to come back we're never
gonna let them nobody can allow that to
come back what our vets had to put up
with I signed the VA Accountability Act
into law
and we've removed more than 9,000 VA
workers who were not giving our veterans
the care respect attention that they've
earned and now that we have
accountability it's accountability very
nice word if an employee of government
mistreats our veterans in any way does
something wrong isn't good for the VA
the secretary looks at them and says you
fired get out before you couldn't do
that
we had people for years and
we had stories I could tell you story
after story how bad it was
you had sadists you had thieves you had
some bad bad people so nine thousand
have been fired and they should have
been fired a long time ago but we got
accountability VA accountability passed
we secured record funding for the VA
including nine point six billion dollars
for mental health services in 2020 nine
point six billion dollars every VA
medical facility now offers same-day
emergency mental health something we
didn't have or even come close to having
we have dramatically expanded telehealth
for our nation's veterans and with kovat
it's really become probably the hottest
thing there is in medicine wouldn't you
say I think so it's gone up in terms of
usage by hundreds of times it was not
picking up until Kovac came along and
now it's one of the hottest things you
have going in the medical world allowing
people to consult with doctors from the
comfort of their homes and not having to
go out and not having to make long trips
and they get tremendous advice to help
the promised White House VA hotline that
I've been talking about has fielded more
than 400,000 calls right in the White
House successfully resolving 98% of
veteran's concerns it's a great thing
we have substantially cut the wait time
for veteran appeals ensuring all issues
are resolved in a swift and timely
fashion goes very quickly now very very
quickly we're modernizing medical
records to begin a seamless transition
from the Department of Defense to the VA
something others have tried and failed
to do they've tried it for decades long
time they wanted to do it it's actually
not as easy as it sounds getting it done
but we got it done
the VA has also cut opioid prescriptions
by 35 percent since 2007
and we're committed to defeating the
opioid epidemic in America we brought it
down by as much as 17% in some areas 19
20 % in other areas but that still means
you have a lot left and but a lot of
good things are happening I have to say
our border where much of this comes in
drugs come in we have a drug problem we
have an opioid problem it's all the same
big problem but our border is now as
secure as it's been in many many years
it's the wall is now up to mile 212 and
wherever we have the wall that takes
care of that area completely but we're
now down to among the lowest numbers
we've ever had on the border and we have
I want to thank the President of Mexico
because we have 17,000 troops right now
on the border Mexican troops and really
helping us a lot the number of veterans
who say they trust the VA services has
increased 19% under this administration
and that's a tremendous increase but I'm
still more impressed it's an all-time
high by the way but I'm still more
impressed by the 90 to 91 percent now
that's the number I'm gonna use from now
on all right can I do that Robert I like
that 91 percent can you imagine if
you're a politician yet a 91 percent
approval rate that would be pretty good
but there's more work to do ending the
tragedy of veteran suicide demands bold
action at every level of society 20
veterans and service members take their
own lives every single day the loss of
our heroes breaks our hearts and pains
our souls one year ago I signed an
executive order establishing prevents
task force to develop a nationwide
strategy to support our veterans in
distress and stop the grave tragedy of
veteran suicide today thanks to the
leadership of secretary Wilkie it's been
outstanding I'm proud to announce that
we are
taking this critical initiative to the
next level
following the ambitious roadmap the task
force has developed over the last year
you'll see things happening that nobody
would have ever thought even possible to
lead this effort missus pence and a team
of ambassadors that she was very much
involved with in choosing including the
Surgeon General Jerome Adams you're only
there Jerome because mrs. pence wanted
to give their okay that's a nice
compliment she's tough that's a nice
compliment will launch a national public
awareness campaign in the coming months
this historic campaign will mobilize
every sector of American society to
encourage heroes in need empower them
with the best prevention practices and
help every veteran thrive in their lives
after service they come home from these
active battlefields and active places
and all of a sudden they're left
sometimes alone and you have a hard time
with it they fought our battles overseas
and now we must join them in winning
this new battle at home there's no
single solution to this issue every
resource must be brought to bear we're
expanding our partnerships with military
and veteran organizations universities
faith-based leaders businesses
nonprofits and all levels of government
to establish specialized support systems
for veterans the task force has already
partners with 30 large corporations to
help them prioritize the mental health
of their employees and we will continue
adding to that number and the numbers
growing very rapidly very very rapidly
we're also launching a national research
strategy that prevents office we'll work
with the greatest scientific minds
across our nation to evaluate research
to better understand the trauma service
members face they face tremendous
tremendous trauma identify effective
treatments and communicate their
findings to the public that prevents
office is currently reviewing the 1.5
billion dollars of federal funding
committed to suicide prevention to make
sure research goes where it is most
needed in order to save lives and to
make lives better here with us today is
former marine and Coast Guardsman Chad
Heiser
who can share with us his personal
testimony about the importance of the
steps we're taking today and Chad if I
could please would you say a few words
mr. president distinguished guests thank
you for allowing me to the opportunity
speak on this vital mission that affects
the veteran community so much the Bible
says in Jeremiah 29:11 for I know the
plans I have for you declares the Lord
plans to prosper you and not harm you
plans to give you a hope in a future god
never wastes a hurt these are the words
I was told long ago by a mentor and
friend but never really understood their
impact until I begin the healing process
from my trauma that I experienced in
combat as a United States Marine on
March 23rd 2003 in one horrific day 18
Marines were killed they were part of
task force Tarawa during the invasion of
Iraq at the Battle of Ana's area three
days later there was a friendly fire
incident which rounds were mistakenly
fired resulting in the injury of Marines
after being honorably discharged at the
end of my enlistment I returned home
feeling guilty for surviving shameful
feelingly I hadn't done enough the war
was still in my mind I was detached
physically emotionally and spiritually I
was angry and isolated from the world
including my family just one year after
leaving the Marines I decided to return
to military service this time with the
United States Coast Guard seeking a
last-ditch effort to cope with the pain
and regain my purpose in life
unfortunately my condition only worsened
in 2005 I attempted suicide
I was transported to a medical hospital
diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder and shortly after I was
medically retired during this time my
wife was praying she was asking God to
help heal me from this combat trauma I
felt there was no one I could turn to
that my life just wasn't worth living as
a tough marine I was hesitant to seek
the help I truly needed to recover 2009
by God's grace and mercy I was saved by
Jesus Christ after carrying these
burdens that I had carried for so long
the newfound hope I had was my
foundation now in 2011 I participated in
Wounded Warrior projects project Odyssey
a combat recovery retreat for the first
time since returning from combat I was
able to open up about my own personal
experiences and help further my own
recovery process this was truly a
turning point in my life that gave me a
sense of new direction as a Wounded
Warrior Project peer mentor warrior
leader a national campaign team member I
am fully committed to serving the
veteran community by giving my time and
attention to listen empathize and
encourage and help carry the burden
shared by countless veterans facing
similar struggles after war I've
realized through my own experience how
vital it is for veterans to have a
positive support system not only within
our families and communities but also
within our government showing support
and caring for those who are hurting
it's also important to let everyone know
what the country know that they can be
strong and ask for help
if you're struggling
stur president i would like to take this
opportunity to personally thank you for
your decision to implement this
important initiative combatting mental
health and suicide crisis within the
veteran community I am so grateful for
your actions and insisting veterans to
get the help they need at such a
critical time your leadership in this
matter
truly shows your care for our nation's
warriors thank you
[Applause]
that's fantastic Chad thank you very
much I thought because she's so
important to what we're doing I could
just prior to secretary Wilkie ask Karen
pence to say a few words and she's going
to be leading us into the Promised Land
on this very tough subject do you mind
please Thank You mr. president I just
want to say thank you for this
administration realizing that this is an
issue that we need to face head-on you
are changing the culture it's it's the
leadership at the top it's people like
Chad being willing to be vulnerable it's
people like dr. van Dalen leading the
whole task force of real experts who
have been dealing with the suicide issue
for many decades and now all of us are
coming together we came together a few
months ago the vice president's
residence we talked about how we wanted
to go forward with this initiative and I
feel like right now is such an opportune
time because we're all dealing with
anxiety we're all dealing with stress
right now so if I can do anything as
lead ambassador it's my goal to help
take away the stigma of mental health
take away the stigma for people to be
able to come forward like Chad to say
there was a time in my life where I
wanted to end everything and our
veterans I've met with so many of them
who say to me I don't go to that dark
place anymore and so we are giving them
hope we want them to know and anyone
who's considering suicide that there are
people out there who want to help there
is a way forward and I just am so
grateful and honored to be lead
ambassador for prevents so Thank You mr.
president
[Music]
thank you very much so she had no idea I
was going to do that but I have to say
that I did it about two months ago I
said maybe Karen wants to say a few
words since she got up and she spoke for
five minutes she blew everybody away she
was the star right Mike and I said come
on Karen you got to go
great great really appreciate it you did
a fantastic job thank you very much mr.
secretary let's go
[Applause]
thank you very much mr. president I have
been accused by some in this room of
living in the 19th century and looking
back on American history before I make
any decisions and I'm going to plead
guilty to that for a second here and say
that in the history of presidential
campaigns and then later the
administration's of a victorious
candidate there has never been a
candidate or a president who put
veterans front and center first of the
campaign and then of the administration
until you did
I I'm going to speak for mrs. pence and
I'm going to speak for myself as the son
of a grievously wounded combat soldier
from Vietnam and in mrs. Pence's case
the mother of a marine war these are
issues that we live with every day and
for the President of the United States
to say it is about time that those who
have carried the burden of freedom on
their shoulders are put front and center
in the national conscience that is an
enormous first step for this nation and
long overdue
I thank mrs. pants I want to thank two
other people first is our executive
director Barbara van Dalen who who took
this burden on herself but took it
joyfully and is not only opening the
aperture when it comes to a discussion
of this last tragic act in a veteran's
life but also opening the aperture on a
discussion they finally having a
discussion on mental health and
addiction so Barbara thank you very much
for what you do and last but not least I
want to thank our Deputy Secretary
Colonel Pamela powers who took this on
when she was chief of staff and has
carried it across the finish line I
thank you very much man
mr. president I'll go back to that
history in the 1890s of one of your
predecessors whose portrait hangs in the
green room was alarmed at the reports he
was receiving from the frontier army of
countless deaths amongst officers and
men on the far outposts of the American
West he was the first president to begin
taking a look at those sad numbers and
it has taken these 130 plus years for
another president to finally say enough
is enough on any given day 20 American
warriors take their own lives those are
active duty Guardsmen reservists the
largest part of that number is from my
father's generation in Vietnam but
another reason why this task force is so
important is that it will point the way
for the rest of the country growing up
as a youngster at Fort Bragg the leading
cause of death amongst my classmates in
junior high and high school was
automobile accidents today it is suicide
it is a scourge that is impacting every
every segment of this country so I want
to thank the president for having the
vision to identify a real solution to
this national problem and that is us
each one of us each one of us can help
end the stigma that has prevented
America from taking on the important
issue of mental health each one of us
can work to change the culture that made
it acceptable to ignore the signs of
mental health and distress each one of
us can learn to identify the signs
amongst our friends our neighbors and
our co-workers so this this day is the
beginning of one of the most important
national discussions America has seen it
is an effort to find a solution to a
problem that does not discriminate
amongst its victim
the poor the rich people of all rigged
races and creeds so I'm going to end
with the story that I've told before and
it was one that I was very familiar with
growing up at Fort Bragg the looming
presence in the home of the airborne was
Matthew Ridgway in fact he was so
powerful that even the minor league
baseball team's mascot is named after
him in Fayetteville
general Ridgway commanded the
all-american division to victory and
North Africa and Sicily and then General
Eisenhower tasked him with leading the
airborne assault on Hitler's fortress
Europe on the night of d-day
general Ridgway planned the operations
for the all Americans the Screaming
Eagles and the Red Devils of the British
1st airborne but on the night of the
invasion he couldn't sleep he fell out
it was caught and he reached for
sustenance in the Old Testament and he
looked to the book of Joshua and God's
promise to Joshua on the eve of the
great battle of Jericho and the Lord
promised the general I will not fail nor
forsake thee mr. president that is what
you have sent to the American people
today and to the 20 million Americans
who are in uniform and who have left
uniform that we will not fail nor
forsake the people of the United States
who have always carried without question
our freedom on their shoulders so mr.
president I thank you very very much
[Applause]
George ugly
so Karen pence says stated beautifully
just a little while ago that the two
words anxiety and stress and all I can
say Mike is thank goodness we don't have
any anxiety or stress in this job with
these people back there but I will tell
you we're working very hard on this
problem and I think we've made a
tremendous amount of progress I even
noticed your number 2020 is different
than 24 you know what that means each
day hard to believe each day but 20 is a
big difference and we're getting it way
down and with some of the treatments
that we're talking about I think it'll
go a lot lower than that and Barbara I
want to thank you very much I want to
thank Chad I want to thank you very much
there's a beautiful beautiful statement
you've done such a fantastic job I see
General Kellogg he's one of our great
generals he's done a fantastic job for
me and he's doing some very important
things for me right now so general thank
you very much really fantastic job and
we will have another meeting soon and
that meeting will be a meeting of
progress because I know with Karen in
charge and with the Surgeon General
working along with Karen and the group
that you have I know every one of them
you're gonna make big big progress very
very fast so thank you very much thank
you Karen thank you very much Mike thank
you
I have characterized this pandemic as a
crisis of health the crisis of the
economy and a social crisis in the
Americas
we have about